it's time for roses and rose' also known
as me getting drunk and talking about
the Bachelorette
what an episode we finally had to say
goodbye to Chad cheers to Chad and his
farewell I say we had to say goodbye
because Chad was great TV Chad says his
final goodbyes and the celebration they
throw promise to whatever Associate
Producer thought of this they through
protein powder in the air they had
fireworks it was a party it was fun so
chad is gone and now we have to find a
way to create conflict this gonna be
tough I love the show but for a while
the most interesting thing that was
happening tonight was there's one dude
whose name I already forgot red Jojo a
poem to try and get himself noticed
cheers to that guy never reads someone a
poem out loud alone do i clap it's just
us but things soon picked up steam and
now I'd like to introduce a fan theory
cheers for fan theories it's what
brought us 50 shades of gray so my
theory is that the producers of The
Bachelorette are giving a little nod to
the show unreal here on unreal season 1
there was a plot about how a producer
planted a tabloid magazine for the
contestants to find creating some drama
on the show this seemed to happen
tonight it's an article about JoJo's X
also name's Chad - Chad's make a right
and then we have one of the best moments
in Bachelorette history
Jojo is inter-confessional and says I'm
so happy right now and the producer goes
from off camera well I have something to
tell you cut to black she reads it right
there on camera descends into tears
which is what she's best at and goes and
talks to the guys that she's like this
isn't me cheers - unreal it's a good
show confronting our past was a theme in
this episode Jojo also confronts Jordan
she said that she hadn't met one of
Jordans exes aka dm's with and that that
exclaimed Jordan is a cheater with
Jordan kind of denies it says that it
wasn't like physical but emotional
that's still cheating
cheers to emotional cheating and then we
had to dive into some drama again
there was an
argument at the end of this episode
between the guys and it was just all
about like I don't know rubbing people
the wrong way I don't know I miss Chad
in the end we said goodbye to all of the
middle-of-the-road guys who were still
remaining like Vinny the barber and
Grant the firefighter they cried
cheers to tears the best part of the
episode was the ending we got a sneak
peek to later in the season and it looks
like the finale it's Jojo on the beach
preparing to get a ring they show a ring
box in a guy's hand and Jojo says she's
gonna dump this guy
it looks very dramatic I am 100% in for
that so what do you guys think I want to
know please let me know your thoughts on
Twitter who do you think she's dumping
in the end what do you think what do you
think what do you think Chad let me pour
one out for you I'm not gonna pour one
out let me drink one for you buddy we'll
miss you bye